chloé est monitrice elle est à la tête
de cette structure depuis un mois son
activité est au point mort
une situation très compliquée c'est très
angoissant mais 25 chevaux ont besoin
d'aliments tous les jours ont besoin de
soins tous les jours et donc sans aucun
revenu c'est très compliqué vous avez
plus de réserves
j'ai quelques réserves mais pas
suffisamment pour tenir le coup
longtemps il y a quelques jours claud et
a lancé un sos auprès de l'association
des maires ruraux de france
résultat un chèque vient de lui être
attribué
l'association perçoit des dons via une
plateforme participative intitulé bouge
ton coq puis les redistribue
intégralement en fonction des dons que
l'on a eues on ne regarde les dossiers
qui ont été transmis par les
bénéficiaires et ensuite suivant la
priorité de la difficulté qu'ont les
entreprises les petites entreprises
rurales
on leur donne un montant qui va jusqu'à
1500 euros
donc plus on a aura de dons plus haut
pour à redistribuer en sachant que
chaque demande doit être validée par le
maire de la commune rurale dans lequel
l'entreprise est implantée une très
bonne nouvelle pour chloé qui va pouvoir
nourrir ses animaux un peu plus
longtemps
un répit pour souffler un peu il faut
pas que ça dure longtemps non non non si
ça dure longtemps
ça va devenir vraiment compliqué
et c'est très très angoissant de ne pas
pouvoir fin de penser qu'on ne va pas
pouvoir subvenir à leurs besoins à
revendre vraiment c'est ce qui me qui
m'angoisse le plus évidemment j'espère
ne pas avoir à en arriver là j'ai pas du
tout envie de me séparer de chloé va
donc devoir patienter et tenir encore un
mois ensuite quand pourra t elle à
nouveau accueillir du public
elle est aujourd'hui dans l'incertitude
la plus totale